sugar Berliner had a very like sweet
style man he was so smooth he just
understood how to how to work the ring
and how to make it look super easy what
was the workout like the work I was
intense
it man I worked I'd actually have to
retrain these sessions I trained in the
morning I'd run sometimes in the morning
and I work out in the evening I sparred
with amateurs or no kidding you did the
whole thing yeah man here's the deal you
can play golf you can play basketball
you can play baseball you can play any
sports you want but you can't play
boxing you got to really look like I do
it no youyou can't play it it's not it I
mean this is warfare man like because
someone's trying to hurt you and I can
completely cause you like life-altering
damage with these fists are you hoping
for Best Supporting Actor in the Sugar
Ray Leonard no no I don't want to get
ahead of myself oh look at you I say
this but it sounds like you've gotten
the acting bug I wanted to be in a full
entertainer not just a musical
entertainer or an actor I wanted to do
it all that's the thing that I'd like to
be recognized that I'd never created a
barrier for myself when I'm done I want
people to say that there's nothing that
this guy didn't try you never tried
juggling you could have been a great
touch